tu cries tu perds le nouveau challenge
pas été inventé par ce quiz et
aujourd'hui on va jouer à un jeu
d'horreur ou plusieurs
ça dépend de la durée de ces derniers il
y aura donc des escrimeurs des petits
monstres qui font pas plaisir et vous
allez devoir fermer vos [ __ ] de
gueuler ne pas crier si tu cries tu
quittes la vidéo et tu cliques sur une
autre vidéo à moi quand même sinon je me
fais un peu plaisir histoire bon erik
christensen jamais qu'assume pas trop
les conséquences
[Musique]
ok on travaille à terre au milieu d'une
forêt c'est parfait situation qui arrive
régulièrement bien sûr à tous les
français au le téléphone qui a pris cher
je dois trouver de l'aide
allez on va trouver la droite wadleigh
t'inquiète pas déjà j'aimerais trouver
une lumière avant de trouver de l'aide
maintenant comment je sais où je dois
aller la map l immense mais qui n'a pas
de sens là bas il ya un truc là c'est
quoi ça est ce qu'on a trouvé une light
la réponse est oui bien évidemment c'est
mieux c'est une allumette c'est quoi ce
bras et les maladies cette personne mais
mon propre bras n'est pas aussi fin mai
que spectaculaire est-ce qu'on peut
allumer une allumette
ok j'ai pas qui est ce package package
ok d'accord dont on pouvait avoir de
lettres juste ici et y obtient d'entrée
dans cette forêt humide et moite bomba
mec
et si on suivait les rails on va suivre
les rails mec tu as une bonne technique
ça suive les rails donc vous avez pas
crié que le pont cpt non mais non mais
non vous allez rester vous allez vous
allez réussir ce challenge en faites pas
on va tous les sirops challenge ont la
banane la lumière royal et où va y aller
sans plus tarder oui une musique qui
stresse et qui est en train de monter tu
sais au [ __ ] une caverne j'ai pas vu
un sa mère ouais la musique s'arrête
quand on entend les cas là il n'est pas
dit que je à l'eau s'il ya quelqu'un
éventuellement dans cette caverne très
tard et à taratata pas une meuf qui sort
de l'eau là comme dans the rings là avec
son puits de merde arrêtez arrêtez tout
ce qui est on oublie s'il vous plaît
m'explique où j'ai perdu allez salut ça
va aller à bientôt
ok nouvelles règles on a trois buts
chacun ont réparti le genre de personne
qui invente des règles pendant le jeu
bon on y va c'est bel et bien un petit
enfant nu comme dans les films
asiatiques qui sort de l'eau on connaît
bien ce petit enfant nu il est très
énervant
[Musique]
c'est pas qu'il ya pas que les mecs sont
elles à houellebecq son sac à d'autres
elle m'a mordu mais dit tu fais ce que
tu veux avec ton corps tu te balader à
poil avec un sac à dos il n'y a pas de
souci par contre j'ai vu demande ce
peuple est scandaleux c'est des arbres
des arbres vivants
je peux regarder elle a mordu l'arbre à
como stupar on lâche tout que ça va un
peu trop loin son délire c'est à dire tu
me more n'y a pas de soucis hockey au
pire ok tu mords un arbre tu mords la
nature je m'appelais une association est
donc tombé dessus direct déjà pourquoi
cet avantage
pourquoi est ce que est ce que peut-être
à la fin on finit en arbre on devient un
arbre sais c'est pas mal sachant qu'un
arbre sa vie mille fois plus longtemps
que nous c'est pas mal très bon ce ne ne
blesse pas ma mère me faisait mais
arrêter tes goûts des [ __ ] armes
salut il a fait ses courses il a fait
ses courses il revient de l'idole
tranquille bourlard ville a acheté de la
coco de la noix de coco
merde j'ai mis feu à son truc
désolé mais cette piste et le chemin en
fait c'était pour qu'il puisse passer je
suis désolé si je t'ai brûler attention
screamer préparez vous pourrez pas vous
préparez vos skis marc ne criait pas ne
criez pas j'aimerais que vous soyez
encore la fin de cette vidéo puisque
tout seul j'assumerai jamais aux sacro
avec l'allumette dans le jeu mais c'est
quoi ça tancés labeouf qui étaient dans
la rue maintenant elle a pris position
de lumière ça qui se passe énorme
d'ouvrir un cinéma 4d ça y est nous
nouvelle carrière pour lui cacher ce
parti de retour dans la forêt un accord
en part sur des bouées deux dogmes qui a
choqué palomeque on va aller chanter
avec lui sabaly mort d'homme ok mec
chanter un petit peu comme ça avec vous
un petit instant comme ça entre nous on
a oublié le contexte n'a oublié les
bruits de pas et le monde ce qui fait
dix-huit mètres devant moi sans oublier
aux mais ce monde et la wii dans la
maison au monde où on a fait tout le
tour
allez on va toqués déjà pour avoir une
maison ici c'est probablement l'oeuvre
qui vit là tout simplement il ya des
lettres un peu pixelisé à l'imprimante
du mec n'était clairement pas au point
un accord je peux rentrer comme ça ah
d'accord tu vas chercher de l'aide ses
tubes raclée gens quoi c'est quoi ces
bruits attend ya un élevage de cochons
cette pièce ou quoi
[Musique]
est ce que il vient de tuer tout le
monde oui parler ya plus de rats ils
partagent sais plus quel chemin suivre
suis perdue à ok c'est là bas c'est
là-bas au bétail au l'air d'avoir mal
mais oui tu je suis seul sous la pluie
davet waouh
non j'ai pas qu'elle ait choqué les
aztèques maire de s'exclamer s'étaient
pas inscrits et une manière un peu un
peu commune de dire oh là là je suis
surpris en fait ça voulait dire oh là là
je suis surpris mais c'est un raccourci
en vidéo c'est plus simple alors à toi
[Musique]
oh mon dieu la sorcière de l'acnoa
sauver merci d'avoir joué ou et sapins
ce jeu-là ce petit jeu d'horreur
gratuits j'ai apprécié tout ce qui s'est
passé durant ce jeu surtout que j'ai pas
crier aucune foi donc ça me fait plaisir
quoi quoi alors tu as vu plus haut cette
séquence parce que je vous aime a levé
ou waouh je ne crie pas voilà les
preuves sont là je suis désolé mais vous
êtes encore là
vous n'êtes toujours pas perdu mais les
amis ça tombe bien deuxième jeu
d'horreur
nous sommes maintenant sur contemple c
est ce que vous êtes content déjà 2 si
vous avez crié puisque cette blague
était hyper nul vous êtes pardonner ses
parents on va pas content et ça comme
une défaite pour challenge
ok faut connaître cette maison c'était
je déteste je déteste quand ça se passe
dans une [ __ ] de maison entre quatre
murs où tu es bien comme un kaka quand
il ya un problème c'est terrible ok on
part dans la grange aux ya bien des
outils pour tuer des gens ici célébrant
avaya la clé nickel alors bonjour je
m'appelle titou en pratique l'opex je
suis pas du tout mal intentionnés esprit
un esprit manifeste toi si tu es la
mecque même le grand jd n'assumerait pas
seul lieu vraiment y'a un truc à faire
ou pas penser j'ai fais j'ai vraiment au
[ __ ] j'ai des frissons pour compenser
gfa et crié sur le craquement de parquer
monga bafoil étage
comme d'hab s'en faut toujours aller à l
étage et quant à l'étagé un mec d'un
coup il au rez-de-chaussée et il te suit
à l'étagé où est ce que je veux dire ok
nouvelle salle de bain très peu
entretenues on a vu qu'on est marin
s'est passé bon allez on va là l'état
j'ai compris mec à 1,8 g plus longue
marche à l'eau what the fuck happened et
j'apprends gone wrong c'est plus drôle
et ça fait même plus de clics donc déjà
tu devrais pas faire ça bon il ya de la
lumière on est content ok on peut ouvrir
cette porte maintenant qu'ils étaient
fermés en plus c'est très bien alors
qu'est ce qu'il ya c'est de la télé
c'est quoi ces métiers seller midi sous
la limite on va pas tarder à parlement
c'est sur un [ __ ] c'est un laitage
alors péché aux yeux du brut pas des
bêtes pour descendre
ok je redescends ya plus rien au live à
sion c'est un truc maintenant oh non je
n'aime pas ça
[Musique]
bâtard je me casse le monstre et l'a
logiquement à pita attention prenez une
inspiration
on y va oh [ __ ] ya le grenier qui
s'est ouvert au caire reprenait expiré
héros pronostique une inspiration ce
parti
[Musique]
alors à nous et nous cassent le le corps
c'est fini hu
personne n'a crié mais on ne va pas
s'arrêter en si bon chemin jeu suivant
et bienvenue ce deuxième jeu l'une à 600
chevaux c'est parti je le rappelle nous
on ne doit pas crier ne criait pas
disclaimer cette vidéo contient des
scènes voilà elle contient des scènes
vous êtes avertis au [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] c'est sûr je vais crier oh
[ __ ] mais je vais crier mais plutôt
plutôt deux fois qu'une comme dirait
morissette
où dois-je aller chez même pas ce jeu va
faire beau ou à monter à l'étagé ça
c'est une belle maison maison à louer
bien sûr n'hésitez pas thème mythes
thème mythes des médias j'aime ça va ça
va ça va thomas gibert du challenge
cherry juste pour te dire je ne rentre
pas avant minuit et en plus tu viens
d'apercevoir d'inconnus trait à la
fenêtre c'est dommage s'il te plaît
l'est et lumières allumées et va dormir
aussitôt que tu le peux je t'aime ta
maman très bien oh oui oh [ __ ] c'est
bon je me sens bien le téléphone peut
être pour appeler la police veut qu'on
vient de voir un inconnu
la ligne est coupée excellent à monter à
l'étagé pas se mettre à l'abri et où une
lettre j'ai trouvé une porte cachée
derrière le cabinet dans notre chambre à
c'est là qu'on doit aller j'ai trouvé la
clé de la porte sur le dessus d'une de
nos tasses de thé lutte armée mais
franchement devoir chercher des trucs
comme ça c'est pas trop ma tasse de thé
quoi donc
c'est pourquoi c'est pourquoi médias je
te permets pas pour commencer tout de
suite a pris mais qu'est ce qu'il faut
je suis là je suis en vidéo tranquille
battu mais pourquoi mais c'est normal
pour toi ça c'est normal mais je suis
outré moi je suis là cherche ma ville et
à se doter comme les merde [ __ ]
où est la clé de la chambre d'hôte à
darron bien il va revenir nous agresser
ce [ __ ] de monsieur à voir mais oui
donc là haut
mother benkei est est en haut à droite
[ __ ] mais des portraits en immense
comme ça personne personne au monde
achète ça oui
allez on y va ok et là il ya la porte
cachée mais ouvre toi à ce moment ce
n'est pas caché dans un carton trang dà
nang attention on est là il ya une porte
cachée ici dame est une [ __ ] de portes
cachées derrière l'amour avec c'est
scandaleux ça allez on y va on y va
essayer dans [ __ ] je pense qu'on a
perdu un cinquième des gens qui au
crillon voyons ça au maire au nom ça
prend une tournure tellement bas dans
cela au nom aken annales et crois qu'ils
se retournent au ca un gros nom du futur
pie tshibanda et eh ben on retourne là
bas
salut
ok elle a disparu on est bien je vais
dans une autre dimension
ah ah ah [ __ ] parquet avait fait chier
mais les maquis comme vers la porte au
secours à un gros match là ça ne va pas
du tout aux [ __ ] des mythes arrête
[ __ ] d'horloge arrête je reste comme
ça en position dans un coin voilà
accroupi au [ __ ]
allô allô pas du tout mec tu apprends
karaté une fois de plus c'est le vous
demande pas de web os au soleil hayatou
gogh stievenard témoin qui jusque là je
me casse oh oui oui qu'est-ce que cet
atelier musique c'est qui s'est joué que
moi [ __ ] désolé mais là je m'y
attendais vraiment pas je suis désolé
arrière la musique s'est mis ça vient
d'où ça vient de là bonjour à tous ces
blogs on dirait que la maison la plante
et de france et tout mon blog urbex part
en couille ap7 faut retourner la
regarder à mon avis on va retourner là
elle apporte bout sera ouvert ça va être
magnifique ce qui va se passer regarder
bien attention voilà voilà il ya plus le
mannequin c'est parfait c'est totalement
le chemin
l'ours non non non non excuse moi
elle n'aime pas être dérangé [ __ ] mais
non mais non faut recommencer du début
mais non mais non mais non mais non j'ai
crié j'ai perdu et bien les amis c'est
la fin de cette vidéo tu cries tu perds
challenge version vous à puce et gaz
n'étaient pas les bonnes habitudes
est ce que vous avez gagné est ce que si
vous n'avez pas crier vous vous sentez
puissant actuellement moi j'ai perdu
vous êtes plus fort que moi
est-ce que c'est étonnant non je vous
dis à bientôt deux prochaines
innovations alors regardez les amis et
puis elle m'a fait bizarre je vois des
tiges et doha ça faisait un moment là
depuis un class ii on a très peu joué à
des jeux d'horreur voilà ça fait
s'appelle cardio tu vois ce que mal à ça
le tapis heureux qui courent ça n'a
aucun sens
[Musique]